متواجد في ازمير امام مقر للعداله
والتنميه حيث بدات الاحتفالات منذ الاعلان
عن فوز الرئيس رجب طيبه اردوغان بولايه
ثانيه احمد فال اطلعنا على الاجواء
الاحتفاليه للعداله والتنميه هناك
[موسيقى]
خلال ايام الماضيه وكنا ننقل غالبا اجواء
مؤيدين حزبي تحالف الشعب
هذه الليله جلال تغيرت الصوره تماما
تستطيع ان ترى الاحتفالات الهائله الجاريه
في وسط هذه المدينه هذا هو المقر الرسمي
لحزب العداله والتنميه في ازمير تقاطر
الناس هنا رجالا ونساء من كافه الاعمار
ليحتفلوا بهذه اللحظه التي يرونها تاريخيه
جلال من خلال احاديثه مع كثير من هؤلاء
الذين ترون في الصوره لاحظوا انهم يشعرون
بان هذه اللحظه تاريخيه بالنسبه
يرون بان هذه ليله في تاريخ تركيا ويبدو
جلال بان طعم النصر يعلو كلما كان الطريق
الى النصر صعبا حيث ان هذه الانتخابات
كانت انتخابات استثنائيه فيما يتعلق
بصعوبه بصعوبتها وبطبيعه الشك والجذب الذي
شهدته فقد واجه حزب العداله والتنميه
وتحالف الجمهور لاول مره
واجهوا تحديات كبيره من اهمها مثلا انهم
عانوا مشاكل اقتصاديه حاده منذ عام 2019
حيث هبطت الليره بشكل غير مسبوق وكذلك
تاثر الاقتصاد وتاثرا كبيرا جدا وقال هذا
كله الى تملمر لدى قطاعات كبيره هذا قاد
الى تصنيع جلال ان ترى الشارع ممتد طول ما
نراه نرى احتفالات نرى ناسا واقفين على
الحيطان يلوحون بالاعلام السيارات مليئه
بالمحتفلين كذلك
اعود الى النقطه التي كنت اتحدث عنها وهي
ان طعم النصر يبدو انه يعلو بسبب العراقيل
الذي كانت في طريق هذا النصر حيث ان حزب
العداله والتنميه واجهت تحديات كبيره خلال
فتره الماضيه وهذا منعكس جلال في المشاعر
الحاده التي طبعت هذه الانتخابات
تابعناها خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين ومن قبل
الانتخابات الاولى الجوله الاولى فهمنا من
خلال الحديث مع الناس وحوارهم ان
الصراع كان قويا جدا كان هناك طريقان كان
هناك فريقان كل منهما يحاول ان ياخذ تركيا
باتجاه سياسي واقتصادي محدد يا اباه الطرف
الاخر لعل ايضا من اسباب شراسه الجوي هنا
في ازمير ان مؤيد الحزب العداله والتنميه
تعودوا على ان هذه المدينه لا تعطيهم
اصواتا بقدر ما يكفي حسب ما يتمنون
النتيجه التي حصل عليها طيب اردوغان في
هذه المدينه اليوم هي اكثر من هي
35% فقط بينما حصل كمالك الجدار اوغلو على
66% وبالتالي هذه الجماهير المتجمره هنا
تشعر بطعم من نصر خاص جدا بسابي البقعه
التي يعيشون بها هذه ازمير القلعه
الكماليه التي يصفونها بانها صامده هذه
المدينه
على ضفاف بحر ايجيا تتميز دائما بمحافظتها
على ما يصيبونه بالاذن الكمال الارث
الكمالي المشاكس على النهج الذي ينتهجه
تحالف الجمهور وحزب العداله والتنميه
وبالتالي كل ما تحدث اليه من هذا الجمهور
الذي ترون عبروا تعبيرا خاصا عن طعم هذه
الليله تعدت مع سيده اتت باطفالها سالتها
قلت لها الليل متاخر جدا فلماذا تاتينا
رغم ان الطرق شبه ملقاه والسيارات كثيره
جدا والارفاع والاصوات مرتفعه قالت هذه
ليله خاصه يجب ان احدث عنها ابنائي يجب ان
اريهم اياها يجب ان اريهم الديمقراطيه
التركيه في ابها صورها يجب ان يشدوها
النحو التي سيعود بها طيب اردوغان الى
اكمال مشروعه حسب قولها
ترى
هذه
الشيعه قال كلمته هذا المساء لكي يواصل
هذا المشروع الكاميرا تدور يسارا جلال حتى
تريكم طبيعه الجو
الاصوات مرتفعه جدا وبيع بالطبيعه ارتفاع
الاصوات ترتفع المشاعر وترتفع الفرح
العالم امام مقر حزب العداله والتنميه في
مدينه ازمير ازمير جلال اذا ما رجعنا
قليلا الى الوراء في هذا المسائل قسمت الى
قسم قسم المحتفل بشكل كبير جدا لعلك تسمعه
جيدا وقسم اخر واجب وهادي تركته في وسط
المدينه وهو القسم الاخر غير المحتمل
بانتصار رجب طيب اردوغان هو القسم المؤيد
لكمال
وعليه في هذا المساء مقسمه كما هي دائما
بين بين هذين الاتجاهين تفضل جلال
شكرا احمد في ازمير من امام مقر لحزب
العداله والتنميه